[Music]
I'm Greg Sadler and I love producing
philosophy content both in YouTube and
in other places that helps lifelong
learners students professionals even
some professors hone their skills and
their understanding in philosophy I take
complex philosophical thinkers texts and
concepts and make them accessible for
all sorts of people I've been on YouTube
now for about six years I've uploaded
over a thousand videos I tend to produce
now about two hundred and fifty videos
each year adding to it and they're
getting a lot of views what I'd like to
talk to you about today is the chance to
support the work that I'm doing which is
pretty much uncompensated and I put a
lot of hours every week every month
every year not only into producing the
videos and doing all the research and
and work that's required for that but
continual interaction with my
subscribers and the people who comment
on the video I offer a lot of additional
you know seminars and workshops and
get-togethers online each month so I'm
really out there doing quite a lot and
people have been asking how can I
support the work that you're doing so
it's time that I actually got on to
patreon if you'd like to support me
every little bit helps
you'll be contributing to my actually
earning living for myself and my family
and you'll be helping to produce a stock
of videos that thousands will really
tens of thousands maybe even hundreds of
thousands of people are finding
incredibly useful not only for their
studies that but for making sense out of
their life for all the different things
that philosophy does so I don't need to
say a lot more about this everything is
in both the links below you can see
where you can sign
funf patreon the last thing that I will
mention is that there's a lot of cool
perks for patreon supporters so if
that's the sort of thing you're
interested in you definitely want to
check it up if you're just wanting to
support those work that I do or give
back or make sure that other people have
the opportunity to see all sorts of
great video content then consider
becoming a supporter I'm going to thank
you in advance and tell you that it's
all going to be used for producing
high-quality content not only as videos
but also the blogging and eventually I'm
hoping to do some podcasting as well so
thanks again and I hope you support
[Music]
[Music]